[Music]
would you want to live at an airport
[ __ ] yeah we live at an airport yeah
like terminal
yeah like terminal the movie terminal or
you mean like the japanese farmer that
lived next to the airport
okay inside the airport [ __ ] yeah no no
no
no way well not lax the chairs are so
uncomfortable
super yeah yeah but you got to go to the
lounges dude
oh yeah well yeah that's baller life
if it was inchon seoul oh yeah that's
a whole ass mall i've never been to
singapore but it looks amazing on crazy
rich asians
it's incredible the turkey uh in
istanbul that airport is dope too
i like it i'm thinking lax though as we
said lax is
rebuilding that's the cool thing but
it's yeah it's still garbage
just too many people for me too many
loud noises right
yeah and too many people yeah people
but doesn't it feel like you're always
about to go somewhere fun
that's why i like the airport yeah but
that's like the excitement of going
somewhere but to live there and not go
anywhere
i want to wake up every day tricking my
mind like i'm about to go somewhere fun
and then i never go
man my plane just keeps getting delayed
yeah it's just a long
purgatory area space yeah it sounds like
a depression cycle you're just gonna
keep going to hudson news and buying
more
buying water bottles and magazines yeah
buy more four dollar sodas and waters
jeez i know it's so expensive like if
you would actually live there
it would go broke because it's way too
expensive to just even eat
but yeah so this man here he lived
in the secure part of the o'hare
airport chicago chicago that was huge
from october 19th 2020
to january 16 2021 holy [ __ ] how that
happened though
undetected oh my god that makes sense
though
because it's 24 hours open some an
airport that big and i think that's
international too right yeah
yeah yeah so this man oh hair is massive
yeah i think i can get away undetected
for a few months at an airport
yeah he was there for three months yeah
so this man
he flew in from l.a but he's from orange
county
and he flew into the chicago airport
and just never left and why he liked the
lights there
his reason is because he was scared of
covid he didn't want to fly back home
so he went to an airport so he went to
the chicago airport stay there for three
months
around lots of people that are traveling
it just makes absolutely no sense it
doesn't i don't understand but
this man he was found out because
he stole a airport workers misplaced
credentials
oh so apparently they're saying that he
survived largely off of
other passengers giving him food i'm
like aren't you scared of kovacs yeah
this guy's dumb
this logic is weird he's a freeloader
yeah well how did he do it he would be
like yeah that's my wallet can you buy
me lunch
i don't know and they'll be like sure
you must be decent because you got into
an airport
right you're traveling because i feel
safe like when you're in an airport i
feel like
it's a different caliber of people was
he through security
yeah secure part the secure part of the
airport you could wait for it you know
some places like you don't have to clean
up after yourself
so you just be waiting and then right
when the people leave the food he goes
and eats the other half of the burger
and not scared of covid huh well i mean
he's that part his logic is weird
exactly i'm sorry that's what i'm saying
he's lying about the i'm scared of covet
that's why i had to stay at an airport
what makes it sound better that's why i
think he broke up with somebody
and got stood up and then that person um
yeah he had to stay at the airport
because he was he didn't want to go back
to l.a
yeah but like living there like was he
living there
like go to like rent a place have you
guys watched terminal
yeah i love it i love the movie because
tom hank i think it's one of those
things where you just get stuck in this
loop
and you just stay there and you don't
know you're just kind of like
not wanting to do anything in life but
just staying there but he lived there
because of immigration
he didn't have a job i thought it was
because of love what
love for what no i mean cath is in the
judgment there
i did i think his plot was he got in
there and they couldn't let
him out because something there was like
a revolution so his passport was like
immediately null yeah
yeah he couldn't go back so he can't go
back and he can't go into did you ever
say how much he spent on airport food
though does that wait
for that i'll kill you in terminal or
this no terminal he made money from
returning the cards
oh yeah right damn i watched this as a
kid i watched the kids dude
that was the fun part wait how old are
you now you don't get coins returning
cards
like they used to do that where you can
get your money back for
returning the cards yeah because you put
one in to use it and then when you get
you get the money back yep terminal came
out and too many people were trying to
steal each other's carts
that was the problem what country was he
from i thought he was from the states
no no he didn't speak english that's
it's funny if you made that movie now
they'd be like you can't have tom hanks
playing this
this guy like you're taking a roll away
from this eastern european eastern
european
the only person that can play sasha
baragon borah
oh catherina jones was in it i forgot
about that i did too actually
hmm anyway like was the spielberg movie
oh was it huh yeah it was the budget was
60 million
i knew that too exciting
but yeah so anyway so he got caught
because of the fact that he stole the
credentials
and because of that reason he was
charged with
impersonation in a restricted area of
the airport and
theft of less than 500 and so
he his bond was set at ten thousand
dollars
and he remained at the chicago airport
he's like i'm living in jail this is
better i know right he's like he's like
whoa what is all this [ __ ] you get food
you get a bed you're already quarantined
whoa
you have to put the chairs together no
it's difficult sleeping at the airport
man
those chairs suck i get it yeah and then
i'm like why do they put the [ __ ]
armrest thingies if like they just don't
want people sleeping i don't think they
want people to sleep
they want it as uncomfortable as
possible so you [ __ ] off yeah but then
i sleep on the floor yep they should
have
more uh airport hotels in the hotel
i mean in the airport some airports have
them yeah like the london one
the one in taipei has one too it's
connected oh and in moscow too what do
you mean
in the airport or right next to the side
of the airport in the airport like you
could walk to it
yeah oh there's one in germany that i
was at
yeah or sometimes they have these like
pods that you can just
like open like rent and it's a pod that
you can sleep in
like like those japanese uh 20 pods yeah
the capsule
capsule pods oh i want to stay in one of
those yeah but those
those hotels are really cool because
they have a shower they have like
everything you need i wonder if you
could pitch in with your friends and get
a pot
because 20 bucks is like man that's a
lot man how about we just like
split it two ways or three you got three
guys just in a pod together
no way can you believe some people take
the train like like
across like the states and [ __ ] like
that's like a form of travel for
that track sounds great i actually kind
of want to do that it kind of looks fun
right because if you get like
the room and like you're just in there
but it takes like a week to get to texas
or some outrageous times thousands more
than plane
too it's more than the plane way more uh
i
saw it one because i was looking into
that and it's like if you get a sick one
with like
that's what i'm talking about like a
bunk bed and another bed and like you
have your own little like dining table
and whatever
like those are like a couple hundred and
then it'll take you trains to have like
a crystal i forgot what they call it but
i'm calling it a crystal cabin
where there's like the entire thing is a
window so you get to see when you're
passing through
nature i think that's the one
that goes from like san diego to san
francisco or something something like
that i'm not talking about the one where
you're just sitting there
like i'm talking about like where you
get your own like little room with the
bed and all that
stuff that's that's like way more than
air travel i guess whenever i think of
like traveling through
train i just think of harry potter
that's all i imagine
no when we were in italy we did take a
train from
i think it was rome to milan we we did
an overnight train
and so we had beds i was like this is
[ __ ] cool i'm sleeping on a train
ty was a pretty it was very
uncomfortable but it was an experience
was it because it was like bumpy and
it was very bumpy and very loud wait you
had like the room thing
yeah and you had real beds yes we had
two bunk beds
so me and casey slept on top and then
aka indiana slept on the bottom
can you reserve it for you guys or like
is it like
random people can come in too no you
reserve it oh
yeah blocked off to you yeah so we got
to it was obviously more expensive than
the regular ones but you know what i
want to do
so it takes more time but yeah there's a
train
that goes from portugal to vietnam
well it's not one but there's a route
that's crazy
and you go from portugal to like germany
from germany to
russia and then from russia you go to
china and then from china you go to
vietnam
that's pretty cool it takes about two
weeks of non-stop
travel though i'd rather do a cruise and
i'm not even a big cruise guy
i love trains though man i don't know
what it is but like
it's the best way to travel in my
opinion because i can walk around and do
whatever i want
hmm oh yeah you can get up i like
getting up that's cool yeah
what is it and it's more spacious than
your train yeah they have restaurants
they have whatever yeah
cruises are like this yeah but yeah but
then cruises you're kind of like this
the whole time yeah it's not
it's in you could stop and get off yeah
and that's the cool part i would love to
do a cruise from
from like miami or new york and then go
to europe and see the atlantic
because oh that's pretty just by doing
that one caribbean cruise
and seeing how calm the water was
compared to the [ __ ]
pacific cruise that we did to ensenada
okay
did the same crew it's like completely
different i want to do a cruise
where i go to antarctica and like to
take a 360 camera and make it look like
my boat's going to fall off
like at the edge yeah well we were we
were looking at the tank line we were
looking at
a well before the pandemic we're looking
at a cruise
that departs from chile and goes to
antarctica
oh that's thai yeah you guys oh we saw
that guy that
that went there he wrote that book yeah
and then he freaking swam
in the antarctic damn this is crazy yeah
he jumped in the water and he swam and
he's like [ __ ] this sneaking back out
because it was too cold
wow you get to see penguins i'll go to
dude antarctica yes it doesn't count as
a combination yeah but at sea world
though you stand
on that thing and it takes you and if
you go by you see all the [ __ ] going
around
yeah you're just kind of like look at
the penguins
yeah dude shit's epic if you love
penguins you go around and then you'll
get to watch it again it's [ __ ]
awesome yup
and i do love hangouts i know exactly
that part two
you're just [ __ ] down and you're
slowly [ __ ] on the bench
he's [ __ ] everyone's always laughing
at them [ __ ] is it like the airport
walking thingies
yeah yeah yeah it's like but you're
sideways for some reason they're like
you know we know
fat pieces this [ __ ] are going to be
here or whatever for they they obviously
don't respect you is what
was why they made this little human
mover thing and so yeah they make you
just like
stand there they're like it's for
americans we know they'll love it
do you think people just hung around too
damn long too
oh that's true that could be the penguin
leave it
like crowding the window too much yeah
it forces them off yeah you know the
penguin link
lingers i was that you're one of them oh
yeah you love the penguins
[Music]